progression and customization are key to
the firaon our experience our game
offers tons of options to the player
that will impact the gear appearance and
abilities of their heroes in fur on our
each of the 12 heroes have dedicated
progression customization options there
are two main avenues to progress and
customize a hero
first at the end of each match players
have a chance to loot gear on the
battlefield each item comes with its own
gear stats gear rank and appearance you
can also unlock gear items in scavenger
crates secondly XP is awarded and used
to level up a selected hero by leveling
up the hero gets access to more feats
and customization options once you enter
the customization menu you immediately
have access to the gear of your selected
hero there are six different gear parts
chest helm and arms for the armor hilt
or handle blade or head and guard for
the weapon from this panel you can
quickly equip or swap gear items that
you have looted on the battlefield
dismantle the ones that you don't want
to keep and upgrade or change their look
each gear item comes with positive and
negative gear stats that affect specific
characteristics of the hero such as
damage defense or max stamina it's
always a trade-off a specific gear item
will boost one or two characteristics at
the cost of one or two others so it's
more about adapting a hero to your play
style than anything else the abilities
panel is where you can customize
gameplay elements of your hero here you
have access to four different categories
feats are the special powers available
in Dominion skirmish and elimination
game modes feats can be equipped in a
heroes menu or in the game lobby before
each battle to start each hero has
access to four feats the eight remaining
ones will be unlocked by leveling up
executions are the finishing moves the
players can trigger when they
victoriously in their fight with a heavy
attack two of them can be equipped at
the same time the longer they are the
more health they give your hero back
when performed to start each hero has
access to two executions while the
others are unlockable with steel emotes
our taunts that are unique to each hero
they don't impact gameplay to start each
hero has access to four different emotes
the remaining ones can be unlocked with
steel and four of them can be equipped
at the same time effects are special
visual effects such as a lightning
strike that can be equipped to provide
additional flavor to an existing move
and don't impact gameplay some can be
unlocked with steel while others a
special reward
Ubisoft Club for instance or in bundles
now let's move to the appearance panel
here players can select what visual
elements they want to customize outfits
are special sets of customizations that
give you a kick-ass look right away
there are four types of outfits battle
elite mythic and reputation in traits
players can select the gender for some
heroes as well as their skin colour in
head right shoulder left shoulder back
and standards players can choose the
paint pattern engraving and symbol that
will be displayed on the corresponding
body or attire part of their hero in
ornaments players can select and equip a
specific ornament to be displayed on
their helmet immaterial players can
choose the base material of their armor
in colors players can choose the three
base colors of their attire for when
they are defenders and attackers in
team-based modes or neutral in duel and
brawl more customization options will be
unlocked by leveling up with all the
different gear items body parts patterns
symbols engravings and outfits you will
have tons and tons of different possible
combinations in for honor to make each
of your heroes play and look totally
unique